[Musique]
les beaux jours arrivent les baignades
aussi et si vous ne savez pas nager
le costume un submersible est fait pour
vous impossible de vous noyer avec la
dernière création de l'office des
inventions
vous pouvez donc partir en vacances pour
nager en toute tranquillité après la
baignade
il faut trouver un abri à l'ombre pour
l'apéritif
l'office des inventions a pensé à tout
avec son hangar gonflable de nouvelle
génération
notre dispositif ne manque pas d'air les
solides transportable et distinguer le
hangar gros fiable épatera tous vos
voisins du camping
pour réserver votre souffle un gonfleur
électrique est vendu séparément